la ruse est astucieuse séduisante mais
vieille comme le monde donnait cinq
mille dollars dans l'espoir de recevoir
un jour quarante mille dollars
cet homme est tombé dans le piège il a
perdu sa mise
il accepte de témoigner mais un visage
caché par crainte de perdre son emploi
c'était vraiment comme du harcèlement
dort jamais une occasion pareille il
faut pas la laisser passer
c'est de l'entr'aide aller en bacs avec
nous les cercles de dons il se présente
comme un cercle d'initiés de gens
privilégiés et qui partagent un intérêt
commun à savoir la partage nude piste on
voyait pas l'aspect leur cantine au
début s'est présenté comme quoi tout est
bien organisé tout est légal même que
c'est déductible d'impôt puisque c'est
pas de la fraude
il existe à l'heure actuelle de nombreux
cercles de dons pays comme le mouvement
du présent ou le won wisdom circle tous
fonctionnent de la même façon en
recrutant de nouveaux joueurs on ne sait
pas quel est le rôle de cette femme au
sein du groupe le mouvement du présent
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'elle organise
régulièrement des séances d'information
elle a refusé notre demande d'entrevue
mais nous écrit tout ce que j'ai fait à
date dans ce mouvement privé à tout
était fait en respectant complètement
est entièrement toutes les lois
canadiennes et joue beaucoup avec les
avec les bons c'est lorsque le public il
y en a discuté avec renault fiat croma
une fraude pyramidale et le phénomène
prend de l'ampleur
le centre antifraude du canada a reçu
cent dix sept plaintes de fraude
pyramidale
au cours des deux dernières années dont
le tiers spécifiquement sur les cercles
de dons c'est interdit dans la creuse
criminel donc c'était quasi de décrier
des exploités et promouvoir mendy par ce
pays essentiellement il ya un vrai
succès c'est un vieux stratagème dans
lequel il y a toujours de nombreux
perdants c'est des histoires qui
racontent juste pour remplir leurs
poches faut pas embarqués parce que
c'est pas on risque de perdre on perd
vraiment ici à nice d'un frisson radio
canada montréal